>> A WRITER FOR THE ATLANTIC
EXPLAIN WHYING SHE IS NOT
INTERESTED IN COVERING HUNTER
BIDEN.
>> MY PROBLEM WITH HUNTER BIDEN
IS IRRELEVANT, NOT WHETHER IT IS
DISINFORMATION.
I DIDN'T THINK THE HUNTER
BIDEN'S BUSINESS RELATIONSHIPS
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH WHO
SHOULD BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I DON'T FIND IT TO BE
INTERESTING, THAT WOULD BE MY
PROBLEM WITH IT AS MAJOR NEWS
STORY.
>> WHAT WAS IN HER HAND?
AN ORB.
THE HUNTER HEADACHE CONTINUES
ISSUE NEW REPORT SAYS JAMES
BIDEN AND HUNTER HAD OVER 150
TRANSACTIONS INVOLVING GLOBAL
BUSINESS AFFAIRS ALLEGEDLY
FLAGGED AS CONCERNING BY U.S.
BANKS, INCLUDING LARGE WIRE
TRANSFERS.
YOU KNOW, DANA, ANN APPLEBAUM IS
HER NAME, I DON'T BLAME HER FOR
DISMISSING A SCANDAL, SHE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL BY NOT COVERING IT,
SHE CAN'T DO IT.
>> Dana: I UNDERSTAND IF YOU ARE
NOT INTERESTED, THAT'S FINE.
NO PROBLEM.
BUT DON'T COMPLAIN THAT OTHERS
ARE.
IF THE "NEW YORK POST" IS
INTERESTED IN A STORY, THEY
SHOULD NOT BE KICKED OFF OF
SOMETHING JUST BECAUSE --
MEANING TWITTER AND BEING
OSTRACIZED FOR SIX MONTHS WHEN
THE MEDIA IS COMING BACK AND
SAYING ACTUALLY THE "NEW YORK
POST" WAS RIGHT.
THAT IS NOT FAIR.
I DON'T LIKE THIS GAME, BUT IF
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD WRITTEN A
LETTER FOR SOMEBODY IN ERIC
TRUMP'S ORBIT, THAT IS ALL THE
MEDIA WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT.
I'M FINE, BE INTERESTED IN
WHATEVER YOU WANT, DON'T
COMPLAIN ABOUT WHAT OTHER PEOPLE
ARE INTERESTED IN.
>> JUDGE, YOU ARE SMILING, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU ARE THINKING
ABOUT, SOMETHING I WANT TO KNOW.
LOOK AT ALL OF THAT.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT KILLS ME
ABOUT THIS, SHE DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT THE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE
HERE, THAT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES LIED TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN ORDER TO GET
ELECTED.
I KNOW NOTHING IS MY SON'S
BUSINESSES, I'VE NEVER DISCUSSED
MY SON'S BUSINESSES WITH HIM.
THAT LAPTOP PROVES THAT THAT IS
A LIE.
FORGET ABOUT THE LETTER OF
RECOMMENDATION, I MEAN, OKAY,
I'LL SAY, I'LL BE FAIR AND
UNBALANCED RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T CARE.
WHAT I CARE ABOUT IS A GUY GOING
TO UKRAINE, WHERE THERE IS
INCREDIBLE CORRUPTION, AND GOING
THERE ON AIR FORCE 2 AND SAYING,
IF YOU DON'T FIRE THE PROSECUTOR
LOOKING AT THE COMPANY THAT MY
SON GETS A FORTUNE FROM, I'M
GOING TO WITHHOLD $600 MILLION
FROM THIS CORRUPT COUNTRY, HOW
DARE YOU USE TAXPAYER MONEY TO
INFLUENCE A FOREIGN COUNTRY TO
MAKE YOUR SON MONEY AND PAY YOUR
BILLS.
WE'RE TALKING FAIR AND TAX ESHG
VAGZ ISSUE FRAUD, MONEY
LAUNDERING, FORGET ABOUT THE
DRUGS, WE ARE TALKING
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEMS WITH
UKRAINE, RUSSIA BEING ON FRONT
BURNER AND THIS GUY GETTING
MONFREALL THOSE PLACES.
>> JESSICA, YOU SAID I CAN'T
BELIEVE PRESIDENT BIDEN HASN'T
RESIGND AND IT DISGUSTED YOU HOW
DEMOCRATS ARE DISMISSING THE
SCHEDULE.
I AGREED WITH YOU AND FOUND YOUR
OPINION REFRESHING.
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS A PRIVATE
CONVERSATION, GREG.
A COUPLE THINGS HERE, PEOPLE
TEND TO FORGET THEM.
SCANDAL THAT PLAGUED HILLARY
CLINTON AND LOST THE RACE IN
2016 ISSUE THE E-MAIL SCANDAL
AND URANIUM ONE, OWNED AND
OPERATE BY THE "NEW YORK TIMES,"
THEY BROKE THE STORY AND PUT IT
ON THE FRONT PAGE EVERY DAMN
DAY.
WHEN PEOPLE SAY THE LIBERAL
MEDIA PROTECT THEIR OWN, NO ONE
MORE OUR OWN THAN HILLARY
CLINTON AND SHE GOT TAKEN DOWN
BY THE LIBERAL MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
SECOND OF ALL, ABOUT THE
PROSECUTOR GETTING FIRED.
JOE BIDEN WENT AND HE WENT ON
TAXPAYER DIME, HE WAS VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
THE WESTERN HEMISPHERE SUPPORTED
THAT.  HISSAC HURT HUNTER BIDEN
BUSINESS INTEREST IN THAT
COUNTRY AT THE TIME AND I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHER WAY TO READ IT, IF
WE'RE BEING HONEST.
>> Judge Jeanine: HOW DID IT
HURT HIM, HE KEPT MAKING MONEY.
>> IT PUT HIM IN A COMPROMISING
POSITION WITH BURISMA.
WE COULD GO ON FOREVER, THIS
GOES ON IN THE PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC SECTOR.
JEENSZ WE'R
>> Judge Jeanine: WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TAXPAYER MONEP.